(birds chirping)
(mosquito buzzing)
- The Dismal Swamp is an environment
that has hazardous conditions
associated with it.
The heat.
You got poisonous snakes
and mosquitoes come out
at certain times of the
year and it's unbearable.
But when you think about some
of the torture the
enslaved peoples endured,
I think if most of us were
living during that day
and we had an option to go
in the swamp and live freely,
I think a lot of us
would take that option.
(birds chirping)
(dramatic music)
- [Yvonne] From the 17th
century until the Civil War,
escaped slaves, known
as maroons, found refuge
in the Great Dismal Swamp.
Located on the border of
Virginia and North Carolina,
the swamp was wild and inhospitable.
Nevertheless, it was there
that runaways created
self-sufficient communities
almost entirely cut off
from the outside world.
For the past 10 years,
archaeologist Dan Sayers
from American University
has been studying these settlements.
- Part of what I did was develop
this sort of research program called
the Great Dismal Swamp Landscape Study.
Most of my focus has been
on archeological discovery
of sites out in the swamp as
well as historical research
and then, of course,
trying to understand it.
Before we started our research,
there was a sense people
lived in the swamp
for a variety of reasons
but we really wanted
to go in the swamp and find remnants
of their lives out there.
And sure enough, we've been able to look
at several sites associated with several
of these different groups.
Probably an 1790 to 1825
or '30 nail that we found
in one of the resistance
community settlements.
I'm sure the population went up and down
but very strong potential
for any given moment
for thousands of people that
went out into the Great Dismal
and formed these
multi-generational communities.
It was a radical form of
resistance in a good way.
- [Yvonne] The runaways
who escaped slavery
risked everything to be free.
Even if it meant living
in the harsh environment of the swamp.
One former slave who briefly lived
in the swamp was a man named Moses Grandy.
- I've done family genealogy research
in which I've uncovered a slave
narrative by Moses Grandy,
who I believe is my great
great grandfather's uncle.
This is Edmond Grandy,
my great great grandfather's headstone,
who was born in 1827.
He was a waterman and a boatsman
on the Dismal Swamp Canal,
which was being hand dug.
And he describes very vividly
in the slave narrative
how they were treated,
what they endured, how they were tortured.
If you had that kind of experience
and you had an opportunity
to come out to the swamp
and live freely under
challenging conditions,
you're gonna have a hard time
getting them out of there.
The idea of Africans
setting up communities
and being in charge of
their destiny in the swamp,
I don't want people to
ever forget this history.